oh no we're [ __ ] up we're [ __ ] up no
no it's fine it's fine it's okay it's
okay we'll just throw we'll just throw
it away
[Music]
hi i'm tyler and my name is elise and we
used to work at ikea hey how's it going
i'm teddy hey i'm nick uh we're cool
dads and it's
nice to meet you
today we're going to be competing to see
who can build ikea furniture the fastest
heights huh because of cool dads yeah
you know
get ready for a lot of that yeah so my
experience with building furniture is
pretty good actually i spent like a
quite a time moment in between jobs as a
handyman our living room it's all billy
book cases so i feel pretty confident
building ikea furniture we have a lot of
ikea stuff so i gotta say i'm pretty
good at it
i might be the weak link here because
although i've been around a lot of ikea
furniture i actually like have not built
a lot i think we're going to kill it
it's going to be fine craftsmanship
definitely i think we're going to smoke
it yeah i think so too we're going to
smash it yeah we'll go get some
meatballs after this exactly a couple
cinnamon rolls after our win to
celebrate
[Music]
ready
set
go
all right let's get the tools yep yeah
let's see what we got here it's like the
rust looks like a uh a chest with
drawers let's lay out
everything we might need we will need
putting the pieces out here
pieces going over here
what is this whatever that oh i don't
think we need that that's for safety we
don't need that step number one
[Music]
i'm assuming is the side panels okay
this is looking pretty simple we'll
start with like a big long one of the
big long rectangles honestly the box
opening is probably the hardest it's all
downhill from here i like to make sure
that i'm orienting everything as it is
in the diagram that way i know that i'm
not like
doing something backwards or upside down
yeah this one's got holes i don't know
what that means is that this one yep
okay
okay we're flying now
oh sick they're just inserting this slot
in it's so easy swedes are so smart you
see they say to use a piece of wood but
i mean
it takes all the fun out of it
oh we don't no no no time for hammers no
time for hammers so we don't have time
for that
okay a little we just do a little that's
fine that's step one done yeah that's
like what like 30 seconds okay so we
need oh
okay okay
literally
shaking right now
i think this is one of those ones where
you can kind of
troubleshoot it
just let it it's a 50 50 toss up yeah
well five nothing step six so then this
is gonna go with the
little
thumbnail
thing good job
this way this is where we need like some
power drills or something i should have
brought my tools yeah
nice nice honestly that's that might be
world record pace a nice thing i like to
do too sometimes is use a little bit of
wood glue when you're doing the
connections here it makes it stay
nice and uh firm
makes it good when you're moving them
too
this is the most chaotic oh my gosh
steady you did a great job everybody's
to damned with the time
we're gonna build quality here
i don't know where this goes
that goes there or something i like i
like that yeah i like it there
is that where it's supposed to go there
[Music]
you got it got it yep
all right now we gotta do is do some
more screwing give it that that dad
pound give it a batch
give it back
oh good all right step five i think
we're doing great time yeah yeah oh no
we stopped we're stuck no no it's fine
it's fine it's okay it's okay we'll just
throw we'll just throw it away you know
you're not building it right unless you
start sweating this is a workout i'm
like sweating i'm sweating too where
does it go does it go up to the top to
the top
oh look they got a little hammer tool
she won't pinch them so you don't pick
your fingers
dad's don't use that
what is that do we even add the backing
they're not going to see it
the back
needs
okay fine we'll do the backing but i
won't like it it's all about
solid contact you just have to make
nice
short
solid
contact
i broke the nail okay
i reckon we can do it just full
okay well
out of the four i'm thinking one of them
has to go in this is one of those it's a
good enough moment see these extra nails
every dad has like an extra screw like
drawer you just throw all your extra
screws
you're gonna need them at some point
okay that's the back oh there where's
that dumb thing putting it in
can we get a close-up on that look at
that once you get to the drawers you're
pretty much you're done it's done i feel
like
like what is that
time so the nice thing about the drawers
is we're gonna make three of them pretty
much you make one you know how to do the
rest so if we're doing drawers it goes
sides
these little
thick ridges go out oh they go like that
yeah now you could get a nice like uh
stain to put on this this is probably a
good
good pine i like to uh make it look like
a nice mahogany you get a nice nice uh
shellac finish even on it
really nice it looks beautiful looks
incredible sturdy as a rock look at that
that so great i think i'm standing on a
nail
this screwdriver is such a ratchet
do you think they rigged the stuff yeah
like they greased it doesn't this does
feel a little greasy
we might want to review the tapes to
make sure that they weren't cheating
i'm sure they're nice guys but
might have sweaty hands yeah sweaty dead
hands you know what i'd say
putting it back on this we really nailed
it
it's getting sweaty i had to put my hair
up oh one other dad tip
righty tighty lefty loosey i think i'm
getting a little over ambitious we are
skipping several steps but yes
these knobs are really
making me break a sweat they're gonna
have a problem when they get to these
moms let's find out do the knobs this
and then this twists
i'll get started on the honestly i think
this is gonna suffice
don't show the judges
it's funny you know i actually got some
drawers myself i gotta build when i get
home
from ikea so this is like a warm up for
me oh
[Music]
what
don't worry about it don't
with ikea some things are like kind of
like optional like you don't need the
backs of the drawers
we're running out of those big ones
oh god these things
we can probably take one off the other
door they don't think we're almost done
we just didn't oh
all right let's just double check
if we can find that other screw you know
you're in the flows when it gets silent
that's that final stretch of like all
right we got this we got it we're still
missing one at least i feel disheartened
no it's okay to be honest i feel a
little disheartened don't give up okay i
won't you're right once you get that in
there's only one thing left to do
some cold brews
there's two things left to do
do we have any nails left probably we
could just nail it yeah we should
totally oh that's a good idea look at
this
[Music]
smooth
yeah
let's see if it goes all the way yeah
that's gonna work
and get ready on time
time
that's a win
look at that look at that strong as an
awkward co-worker look at that
co-workers
for life the ikea rust
i mean you know the drawers open and
close nicely and it functions
it gets the job done
i found the oh you were sitting on it i
was sitting on it great wow very good
okay nothing unique not a lot yeah no
that's the first thing i thought was no
personality like no yeah but basically
cute solid craftsmanship
sorry
i bet like it probably has functionality
yeah yeah
it has drawers i mean yeah yeah it's got
drawers that open and closed you know i
mean you can use it
yeah same without
functional functionality
how hard you want like
i think it's a close call i think it's a
closed call i think it's also a close
call like you guys have the
functionality but we may be like one on
the time portion yeah the best part is
we didn't cut any corners no we played
it just like we were saying earlier we
like playing by the rules it looks like
you guys just left them didn't have to
cut them
there it is
and it's functional it works you know
laying your parts out
going through the directions first
before you know starting just so you see
the road map and uh the train tracks
have been laid for you that you're gonna
be going down look at the pictures yeah
i mean
it helps but most of all just have fun
with it
i think that's what we all do good good
job
[Music]
you